Here are the steps for attaching
the four color changer on a DM-80.
The first thing to recognize is
that the fasteners that attach both
the extension plate and the color
changer itself are in two parts.
There's a threaded post
and a threaded nut.
If you remove the nut, sometimes
the threaded post will also be removed.
Use a screwdriver to separate them.
When installing the extension plate or
the color changer,
first insert and tighten the threaded
post, then attach the threaded nut,
leaving it loose enough to slip
the attachments with their openings.
The extension and the color
changer will be attached here.
Then, tighten the nuts
to secure the attachments.
The four-color changer also requires
this curved cam with three screws.
the cam has three parts connected
with those three screws.
Loosen the screws and attach the cam
to the bed by inserting the round
rod into the slot of the bed.
Slide it to the left until it
stops and then tighten the screws.
When the four-color changer is installed,
it fits snugly against that curved cam.